- Today's video is
sponsored by Skillshare,
so warm thank you to the
whole Skillshare team
to supporting the work on
my channel, Firm Learning.
In the past, I worked for
six years at McKinsey,
but before that, I also
spent about half a year
at the IT consulting firm, Accenture.
So in this video, I wanna
contrast these two experiences.
I will talk about what the
differences and similarities are
of working in an MBB consulting firm
and of working in a IT consulting firm.
Now, I do not wanna make
this about any specific firm,
So while, of course,
this video is influenced
by my experiences at
McKinsey and at Accenture,
I also talked to other people working
at other consulting
firms in these two groups
to make sure you have
a well-rounded picture
of all of this.
And, of course, I need to make
the caveat in the beginning
that while I'm generalizing
now a little bit in this video,
of course, projects within one firm
can be very different from each other,
firms which in the IT consulting
or MBB sector can be quite different,
so, of course, take this
with a grain of salt,
but I do believe that this can give you
a good and solid understanding
of what the differences
are, and of course,
I hope that this can also
inform your career decisions,
and help you understand what
you actually want for yourself
if you are thinking about joining a firm
in each of these two groups.
So while I come to another coffee break
on my channel, Firm Learning,
hope you all had a good
start to the new year.
On my channel, Firm Learning,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career,
talking about topics like
career communication,
management, consulting, personal finance,
and other related things to that.
So without further ado,
let's jump into it,
and today I wanna talk
about five distinct areas
of similarities and differences,
and these are the team size,
the duration of projects,
the type of work that you do,
the background of your colleagues,
and of course, the whole work/life balance
and lifestyle aspect of it as well.
So let's start by the team size,
because I do believe
that this is one of the most
significant differences,
because on average, the team size
in these IT consulting
projects is much larger.
Again this will differ,
and you find deviations for
that in both directions,
but at an MBB firm, the typical team size
is two to five people,
including the project lead,
so as a consultant, you are
one of two to five people
on the team.
This is very different than working
on a large IT consulting project,
which can easily have 20, 30,
40, 50 people, or even more,
on the senior consulting team.
So for instance, you might
work on an SAP implementation,
so a project where your help your client
to implement a new ERP
system, such as SAP,
within their own organization
and with their own teams.
So the plus of working
in such a large team
in IT consulting is, of course,
that you have the opportunity
to talk to many of your colleagues.
Maybe there are some
with whom you don't get along that well,
but then you would still have plenty
of other people to choose from
with whom you can bond,
from whom you can learn,
and then maybe also do
some things together
in your free time.
But of course this also means
that often, your responsibility
in the whole project
will be a bit smaller compared
to these smaller teams.
If you're one of 30, one of
40, one of 50 people, of course
the type of tasks that you
will do will be quite different
because indeed, at a typical MBB project,
you are one of only two, three
or four people on the team,
so you will, from the very beginning,
have a crucial role on that team.
If you do not get the work done,
the team does not have
enough slack, usually,
to just pick up your work,
do your work for you.
This is not how it works.
And of course, there's more
room like that in a larger team.
So this leads me to my second point,
and this is the duration
of such a typical project,
and here the main difference is
that the projects in IT consulting
often go considerably longer than in MBB.
So a typical MBB project
will be three to five months.
There are also projects which
only go a couple of weeks.
The shortest project that
I worked at at McKinsey
was only for two weeks.
And yes, there are also
projects which go longer,
but then there is the
understanding that you're released
after six, seven month,
maybe eight month, latest,
that then you will roll off the project,
and then some other
consultant will roll on
and take your spot.
This is different from IT consulting,
and especially in these large
implementation projects,
you can easily be stuck
for one or even two years
on a specific project.
There, this culture of
rolling off the project
after only a couple of month
is not really established
And of course there's also client pressure
to have the consultants
on the team for longer,
because of course, over time,
the consultants will get experience,
will learn the intrinsics
of a specific company,
So, of course, the client is pushing
for keeping the consultant
on the team longer,
and then this is exactly what will happen
in these typical large IT
implementation projects.
So if you join consulting
because you want to see
lots of different things
in a short amount of time,
I believe that the value proposition
of these MBB projects is much larger,
much more valuable to you.
Of course, the advantage
of being on these projects
that go really longer,
for one or two years,
is that you can really build
much deeper client relationships.
You have the opportunity
to really see something being implemented
from the conceptualization
in the beginning
up until the point that the whole system,
the thing that you're implementing,
is really going live, is really working.
Of course, this can give you
a tremendous sense of achievement,
a tremendous sense of accomplishment,
which maybe you don't experience
that way on an MBB project
because very often, you
leave after the strategy,
after the concept has been developed,
and then it's up to the organization,
or maybe another consulting team,
to then do the implementation.
Thanks again to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people.
You can explore new skills,
deepen your passions,
and get lost in creativity.
There are classes on
marketing, personal branding,
presentations skills, and many more.
All of these are topics
that are highly applicable
to a career in consulting,
banking, or corporate.
And the best thing is that
I made a slide writing class
for Skillshare,
so can access and enjoy
it as a Skillshare member.
Personally, I recently took the class
Productivity Masterclass,
Principles and Tools to
Boost Your Productivity,
from the fellow YouTuber, Ali Abdaal.
It's a great class that taught me
many new aspects of productivity,
and I very much enjoyed how he applied
the Pareto Principle, or the
80/20 rule, to productivity.
Classes on Skillshare are
specifically curated for learning.
There are no ads.
They're always launching
new premium classes,
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your
creativity takes you.
And the best thing is that
it's less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription.
Skillshare created a special offer
for subscribers of this
channel, Firm Learning,
and so the first thousand
subscribers of me
that click on the the Skillshare link
in the video description
will get a free trial of the
Skillshare premium membership.
I hope this helps you to
explore your creativity.
Check it out, link in
the video description.
And now this indeed leads
to the third aspect I wanna talk about,
and this is the type of work
that you will be tasked with.
On such a big IT project, of course,
your work will be much more hands-on.
You might work with Big Data cubes
that you help the client setting up
in order to then build a BI,
a business information system,
to help the client analyze its data.
Or you might migrate data
from one system to the other
in order then to really make the migration
to a new ERP or SAP system, for instance.
You might dig deep into the
processes of the client,
really mapping out all these processes
and then translating them
into an IT system that
the client is using.
Overall, the work will
be much more oriented
towards implementation, towards
getting these things done.
And this, of course, can be
contrasted to work at MBB,
but it's much more theoretical, right?
You often develop concepts, strategies.
The end result of your work
will typically not be a running IT system
but rather a document, maybe
a PowerPoint presentation.
And here is where times
are changing a bit.
Now also MBB is doing some of
these other things as well.
Now I'm also already
foreseeing all the comments
from the IT consulting
guys that will tell me
that of course, in IT consulting,
you do these conceptual tasks as well.
So yes, all of this is correct,
but if you talk about the
tendencies, the directions,
I do think that this
distinction is very relative.
And this is actually something
that I found very
interesting and inspiring
when I worked at Accenture
in IT consulting,
because of course,
on these large IT implementation projects,
you will often work together
with computer scientists,
with people that really
do the implementation,
that can code, that
can set up the systems.
The way that these people
work and think about things
of course is quite different
from the typical consultant
that you might sit together
in a team room, in an MBB project.
So probably, the profiles
of the people you work with
are a bit more heterogeneous,
and I did found this very enriching.
Of course, the backgrounds
of the people you work with
are quite different at MBB as well,
but I think it's fair to say
that the mindset of these
people, the whole way of working,
was a bit more homogeneous
than what I found in IT consulting.
But of course, the upside
of working together
with these people at MBB
is that because, allegedly,
MBB have the most selective
consulting recruiting processes,
you really get to meet
extremely inspirational,
extremely ambitious,
extremely driven people
in these MBB consulting firms,
so while their profiles might
be a bit more homogeneous,
you can trust that the
learning that you will get
out of working with these
people will be insane,
and this of course is a huge plus
for working at an MBB firm.
And the fifth point I wanna
talk about is the lifestyle.
So first of all the similarities.
So both IT consulting and MBB consulting
share this lifestyle of
traveling to the client,
being at the client
from Monday to Thursday,
and then usually having an office Friday,
and then more or less a free weekend.
So these are the
similarities you can expect
that usually, again on
average, and again I know
that this might change
also, project by project,
usually, the lifestyle
will be a bit better
in IT consulting.
So from my very personal experiences,
usually people were
leaving the client site
at around 7:00 p.m.,
sometimes even earlier,
and if we stayed at the
client until 8:00 p.m,
this was already a long day.
And also once the people
left the client site
and worked from the hotel,
I didn't really perceive the culture
of then still continuing
to work in your hotel room,
continuing to work in the evening.
And this is of course very different
from what you need to expect
if you work at an MBB firm,
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
If you want to learn more about that,
check out the video that I did
about a typical work week
at an MBB consulting firm.
So what you will clearly see there is
that what you can expect is
that you really need to work much longer,
so usually, if you're
completely done at 10:00 p.m,
this will be considered a good day,
and there will be many days where you work
until midnight, or even later.
Of course, the upside of
working at MBB consulting
is that the pay is usually
significantly higher.
You can easily expect
to earn 50% more at MBB
compared to IT consulting
on the entry levels,
and then this gap will only widen
the more senior you become.
So now I'd of course be
interested to hear from you.
So if you work at an MBB firm
or an IT consulting firm,
just leave me a comment below
whether you believe that I
characterized this correctly,
or maybe you have your own experiences,
your own insights to share.
I believe this would be
valuable to many other people
here in the Firm Learning
community as well.
So thanks a lot in
advance to your comments.
And as always I will answer
to every single comment that you write,
and, of course, the
comments help me as well
because the more comments the video get,
the better this looks
to the YouTube systems.
So if you took any value out
of this YouTube video at all,
please hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram.
I recently had 10,000
followers on Instagram,
so thank you for that.
I also have a mailing list,
you can sign up to that
in the link in the video description,
and you can also reach
out to me on LinkedIn.
Again, you can find the
link to my LinkedIn below
in the video description.
Thanks again to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video,
and do not forget to join them
via the link below in
the video description.
And I also wanna say thank you
to the members of this channel.
You're really supporting me with my work,
and if you're considering
to become a member as well,
hit the Join button next
to the Subscribe button
to learn about all the perks.
So if you watched until the end,
please let me know that
as well in the comments.
Very much appreciate that.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So looking forward to next week,
to talking to you there again.
Until then, a good weekend to all of you.
Have a good start to the new year.
This is Heinrich from
Firm Learning, bye-bye.